[Musique]
la
potion la
[Musique]
PO est
part mais ça va demain n enfants naura
plus rien Nura plus oiseaux ni la nature
nous l'
[Musique]
détr la potion
partoutou
[Musique]
la nous dis nous n petit pays mais voilà
nous détruit nousous n petit pays mais
voilà nous détr la
[Musique]
PO la
PO les
[Musique]
cons la
Réunion ntit pays c'est le
paradis il faut pas
[Musique]
la pouvoir publ fait pas
rien
pay
[Musique]
un vieux canapé un T de grab un bou de
fer rouillé un vieux chassé un
frigidaire un papioto un chien crevé
tout le monde jette n'importe
quoi nous dit c'est les autres il fait
mais seraitant n regarde un coup n
portrait moi me dit changeun manière
manière réserve la nature mon
frère jette plus rien à terre fa change
comportement rien j'ai plus rien avant
les trop tard rien plus rien la nature
les B rien plus rien les p poubelle r on
protège la
Terre plus rien ou il est plus Ren j'ai
plus rien la nature plus Ren j'ai plus
rien arrête
exord préserve la
[Musique]
nature